PROFESSOR: Examine every
possible means for combining
the symmetry at once, but
there is a seemingly
paradoxical trick that
we can yet pull.
And let me indicate what
is true here for 2mm.
OK, so this is a twofold axis.
Has mirror planes perpendicular
to it.
If one of these is a mirror
plane, the other one has to be
a mirror plane as well.
So there's no way we could make
one a mirror plane and
one a glide plane.
OK, that requires a net that
is exactly rectangular.
So let's put in the
twofold axis.
And I add one to the
corner of the cell.
As we well know we have to have
twofold axes at all of
these other locations.
We want to put a mirror
plane in the cell.
We could pass it through the
twofold axis, and that would
be the same as P getting
to P2mn back again.
But why do we have to put the
mirror plane through the
twofold axis?
We have to have the twofold axis
left unchanged when we
add the mirror plane, because
if we created a new twofold
axis we create a new lattice
and we'd wreck the lattice
that we've constructed.
But why, why, oh why couldn't
we put the mirror
plane in like this?
That's going to leave the
twofold axis alone.
It's going to leave the
translations invariant.
Why don't we do that?
Why not?
So here, trick number five,
or wherever we are now.
You can add the symmetry
elements of a point group to a
lattice, but not necessarily
at the same point.
You can interweave them.
But the constraint is that this
addition must leave the
axis invariant.
Let's leave the twofold
And vice versa.
That is to say the mirror
planes can't create new
twofold axes, the twofold
axis can't
create new mirror planes.
And let's make sure we
understand the reason why.
If I've got a twofold axis here
and a twofold axis here,
I have to have a translation
that's twice their separation.
If this distance is delta,
then I have to have a
translation that's
automatically
created at twice delta.
This is the same as saying
twofold axis with a
translation gives you a twofold
axis halfway along.
If I take the twofold axis, I
get the translation back as a
consequence.
So what I'm saying is if we take
the first twofold axis
and repeat number one to number
two, and then add
another twofold axis which
repeats number two to number
three, you have a third one that
is related by translation
of twice delta.
So if you're going to interweave
the symmetry
elements, you have to leave the
arrangement of symmetry
elements at the same intervals,
otherwise you would
have created a translation or
more that is incommensurate
and incompatible with
the other ones.
So this is a third trick.
And we are going to need
a new theorem.
Let's first of all look
at the possibilities.
We can have the twofold
axis interweave
with a mirror plane.
How about putting
a glide plane in
between the twofold axis.
In other words, replace the
mirror plane by a glide plane.
This twofold axis hangs off
here, reflect it across and
slide it down to here, and you
get this twofold axis here.
So that's also a self consistent
compatible
arrangement.
How about a centered net?
And that's more difficult.
A centered net has twofold axis
and all the places of C2,
and then twofold axes at
locations like one quarter,
one quarter as well.
We can't put a mirror
plane in here.
That's not going to work,
because it will generate a new
twofold axis, and that changes
the translation
T1 to half its value.
We can't even put a glide plane
here because this would
slide down to here, reflect
across, and that's
not going to work.
So the number of possibilities
is limited, but we'll see that
there's one other case as well
for a fourfold axis.
OK, we need a new combination
theorem that says if you have
an operation a, pi, and combine
it with a reflection
operation that's removed from
it by some distance delta,
what is the result?
That general theorem has worked
out for you on the
notes, but I think what I'll do
it in the interest of time
is simply look at how this
arrangement of symmetry
elements would move
things around.
And here I've taken the motif
and hung it at the lattice
point, and repeated it
by the twofold axis.
The mirror plane would take this
and reflected it across
to here, then take this one and
reflect it across to here.
And do the same thing down at
the bottom of the cell.
Let me now ask you what sort of
plane has arisen that would
be perpendicular to
the mirror plane?
Could be interweaved or passed
through the twofold axis.
Anybody want to hazard
an answer?
OK.
We have to have some sort of
correspondence theorem that
says if you've got a twofold
axis, have one plane, you've
got to have another plane
90 degrees away.
Do I know how everything
is related?
I know how this is
related to this.
I know this is related
to this.
That's by a reflection plane.
I know how the twofold
axes relate things.
How is this pair related
to this pair?
And the answer is that the way
they are related is by rights
and lefts on here.
This is right, this is right.
Reflection changes handedness
to left, so I've got to have
some way of getting from this
pair to this pair that
involves a change
of handedness.
And I see nobody is really
jumping out of their seat, but
there is a glide
plane in here.
Take this pair, slide it along
by half of T2, and flip it
across by reflection.
And there is a glide
plane right here.
And therefore of necessity
there's a glide plane here.
And this glide combined with the
perpendicular translation
will put a glide plane
in here as well.
And you look in your tables.
This is plane group
number seven.
And this one has
a twofold axis.
It has a primitive rectangular
neck, so this is called P2m,
and now the second plane at
right angles is not an mirror
plane, it's a glide plane.
So this is called P2mg, or
there's a shorthand form that
leaves out the two.
PMG is the shorthand
symbol for it.
So there's a new plane group
that is based on orthogonal
symmetry planes.
One a mirror, one a glide,
and twofold axes.
Let me ask you now what is the
point group of a crystal that
would have this relation between
the atoms that are
down in the guts
of the crystal?
What would be the point
group of the crystal?
We've got two different
point groups.
We've got point M, we've
got point group two.
What would be the point
group of the crystal?
And this is a new problem,
a new concept.
All of the plane groups that we
looked at until this point,
the symmetry elements on an
atomic scale down inside the
plane group were exactly the
same as the point group that
we had added to the
lattice points.
But here we've got two different
point groups that
had been put into the lattice.
So do we say that this
crystal has symmetry
two or symmetry M?
Or just point group 2m.
That won't work because if you
have one mirror plane in a
point group, you have
to have another.
What this introduces is
a very subtle point.
The point group is inherently
a macroscopic symmetry.
When I say a crystal has a
particular point group, what I
mean is that if I look at the
exterior faces of the crystal,
I would say there's a
twofold axis here.
And that's about all, if these
spaces are pair wise distinct.
I have a crystal that looks
like this externally.
I would say that that crystal
has symmetry 2mm
based on the faces.
If I found that the etch pits on
the surfaces were not quite
the same on this face and this
face, I would have to throw
out the twofold axis, perhaps,
which means this mirror plane
would go out as well.
But also I would do things
like look at the optical
properties.
I would measure the
conductivity as
a function of direction.
I would look at the slip systems
and yield stresses in
different directions, and the
assignment of a point group is
an experimental observation that
requires that you look at
all possible properties.
Not only shape, but properties
like conductivity and the
magnetic susceptibility, and
also perhaps the way the
crystal diffracts X-Rays.
That's another physical
property.
And then when you've done as
many measurements as you
choose to make, you say as far
as I can tell, all behavior of
this crystal is determined
inconsistent with this
particular point group.
But you're doing macroscopic
things.
You're doing macroscopic
When you talk about the plane
group or space group, you're
talking what goes on on
a local atomistic
scale in the unit cell.
So what would be the point
group of this crystal?
It would have a twofold axis
that would be manifested
externally.
It would have a mirror plane,
which makes the left hand side
want to be the same as
the right hand side.
And if this were not a mirror
plane here, but a glide plane,
what you would say is that this
face, if I reflect it and
slide it along by one angstrom
is going to become this face.
And this face here, if I reflect
it and slide it back
by one angstrom is going
to become this face.
But what will that do to
the external shape?
I just extend all these
surfaces, and it's going to be
exactly what I've drawn here.
How would you distinguish
a mirror plane
from a glide plane?
If a crystal has a mirror plane,
a face that sits here
passes through some atoms.
Those atoms are repeated
by reflection.
And being slit up by an amount
tau which is on the scale of
atomic dimensions, and
that would give
rise to a face here.
But can you macroscopically
assign any difference to the
fact that two faces
atomistically don't meet, but
are separated by
3.2 angstroms?
No.
What you see is one face like
this, and one face inclined to
it with a slope that is the same
for either a glide plane
or a mirror plane.
So another truth about
crystals is that
macroscopically a glide line
plane manifests itself as a
mirror plane.
So paradoxically this crystal,
which only has a twofold axis
and one mirror plane down in its
guts is going to look as
though it has point group two in
it, even though there is no
sight, atomistically within this
arrangement of atoms that
has symmetry 2mm.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's a very
good question.
And actually, to answer it
properly requires knowing
something about diffraction.
The symmetry of the diffraction
pattern that you
observed would look as though
it had a mirror plane in it.
Which is to say if we put a beam
of white radiation down
along this direction of a
crystal, imagine these things
all extending out in a third
dimension, that what we would
see among the arrangement of
spots is a twofold axis in the
center of [INAUDIBLE]
photograph we'd see a mirror
plane running this way, and a
mirror plane running this way.
So we would see spots on the
[INAUDIBLE] pattern, which
would look like this.
So the glide plane would
also behave it
were a mirrored plane.
And, maybe, if you
think of what
goes on with the fraction.
If you ask yourself, if I
brought in x-rays this way and
diffracted them off a layer of
atoms related by this glide
plane, and then I can't do this
actually to the crystal.
But, suppose I then inverted the
direction of the incoming
beam, and slitted along
by five angstroms.
Doesn't make any sense.
The diffraction from these
planes is going to look the
same whether I bring in from
one side or the other.
So a glide plane, in diffraction
symmetry,
manifests itself as
a mirror plane.
So how can you determine the
presence of glide planes using
diffraction?
And you can.
And the answer is, that the
glide plane causes the
intensity diffracted it from
planes with certain indices to
be identically zero.
You've probably heard of these
magical extinction rules
they're called.
And it says that if h plus k,
plus three times L is two pi
plus four, and the crystal is
green, then you've got such
and such, the reflection
being absent.
Actually it is--
I'm getting distracted-- but, it
turns out that glide planes
affect just a sheet
of reflections
in reciprocal space.
And the reason some reflections
are absent is that
that sheet of reflections
corresponds to what the
projection of the structure
onto that plane would do.
And, if you project a structure
that has a glide
operation onto the plane of the
glide plane, the structure
looks like the lattice
translation is half as big.
And, if that's the case, the
diffraction spots are twice as
widely separated.
And it turns out that all of the
reflections that have an
index corresponding to the
direction of tau are absent if
that index is odd.
So, if you knew a little bit
about it to begin with, that
perhaps answers the question.
So yes, you can determine the
presence of glide planes.
And later on, we'll talk
about screw axes.
You can determine their presence
unambiguously, but
you do that not the symmetry
of the diffraction effects,
but from systematic absences.
OK, another thing I suggested we
could do is to put a glide
plane in between the
two-fold axes
instead of a mirror plane.
And this says that I have a pair
of atoms repeated by the
two-fold axis, the glide plane
would take that pair, shift
them down by half of the cell,
and reflect them over.
So this would be the
pattern of objects.
This is not a lattice point,
because if these are right
handed, that's a right-handed
pair, this is
a left-handed pair.
Now let me try you again.
I know how these guys left
and right to this
glide plane are related.
How about these ones that are
up, to the ones that are down
here in the middle
of the cell?
There's got to be, from our
correspondence principle, some
plane going in this direction.
Anybody want to hazard a
guess at what it is?
The answer to that question
resoundingly is, no, not at
this hour the afternoon,
thank you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Left one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, very good.
Right ones have to go left ones,
and they're going to go
left and right about
these planes here.
And, if I combine this glide
plane with t2, there has to be
another glide plane in here.
If I combine this glide plane
with t1, there'll have to be
another glide plane in here.
OK, and that turns out to be
plane group number eight,
P2gg, not P2mm, both mirror
planes have become glide.
All right, we're almost there.
If you look at the hexagonal
symmetries, there is just no
way that you can interweave
things, and an attempt is made
in the notes that
I handed out.
You just cannot do it.
But with P4M, P4, there is
one final possibility.
And I'll just set that up
and not carry them out.
OK, I'm going to put on just P4
with twofold axes in here.
Now we have planes that go in
orientations like this.
And then there is another plane
45 degrees away that is
a symmetry independent plane.
And the question now, I'll let
you have a crack at it, is
there any way in which I could
take planes in the diagonal
orientation or parallel to the
cell edge and interweave them
in between the rotation axes
in such a fashion that the
rotation axes were
left invariant?
Again, conversely if they're
not left invariant, we will
have created new translations
and wreck the lattice.
So how could we slip in planes,
either reflection or
glide, and leave the
axes invariant?
AUDIENCE: One quarter
and three quarters?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Do you want parallel
to the cell edge?
AUDIENCE: Horizontal.
PROFESSOR: Horizontal?
Yeah.
This [INAUDIBLE]
here has a fourfold axis up,
a fourfold axis down, a
fourfold axis up.
Twofold axis down, twofold axis
up, twofold axis down.
So this would be a lovely
location for a glide plane.
So that's one.
From the fact that I am placing
the same diagram on
the board yet again suggests
that there's another way.
That's a perfectly good
suggestion, and that's one of
the things we would
have to examine.
Is there any other way I could
put in a mirror plane or a
glide plane and leave
the axes invariant?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
45 degrees?
PROFESSOR: 45 degrees.
Through here.
I don't want to do it through
here because the fourfold axes
sit on the same side, but you
want to put it in like this?
I don't think you can do that.
Glide plane won't work here.
How about a mirror plane?
There's no mirror plane that
goes through these twofold
axes for P4mm.
What we had there were mirror
planes here, and then going
this way were glide planes.
We've already got that.
How about putting in a mirror
plane like that?
This goes into this.
Halfway along there would have
to be another mirror plane in
that orientation.
Here's a twofold axis that
demands that there has to be
another one if it has a mirror
plane passing through it.
So there's another way.
One final one, and I will not
keep you guessing anymore,
sneaking a peak at the answer.
There is another way you could
do it, and that would be to
put the glide plane down
diagonally through the cell.
That is put the glide
plane here.
That and take this twofold axis,
reflect it across to
here, and slide it
down to here.
So this twofold axis would be
related to this one by glide.
So those three possibilities are
available for point group
4mm and a square net.
If you try them, and the simple
way of doing it without
any general theorem would be
to draw in the way the
symmetry elements repeat the
motifs, and then ask what they
require for the remaining
symmetry elements.
All of these give the
final result.
So they yield the same result.
You can develop a general
theorem for what you obtain if
you have an operation a, alpha
combined with a plane, and
make it a general plan, a glide
plane that is removed
from the axis by some
distance delta.
And that theorem is written out
for you in the notes on
the very first page.
You take a glide plane, and this
is a specific example, a,
pi, if you have a glide plane
that misses a twofold axis by
some distance delta, then the
effect of those two successive
operations is a glide plane at
90 degrees to the first, and
it's removed from the twofold
axis by two delta.
It has a glide component,
excuse me, has a glide
component two delta.
So there's a general theorem
for the twofold rotation.
The general theorem for a
fourfold or a threefold
rotation is considerably more
complex to derive, but that's
contained for you in
the notes as well.
All right, we've come to the end
of one other major part of
our story of symmetry.
These are the periodic
patterns in a
two dimensional space.
And these are then the 17
crystallographic plane groups.
Crystallographic is rather
redundant because they are
groups that have [? in ?]
translation and therefore
these are the symmetries, the
two dimensional symmetries
that are suitable
for the atomic
arrangements in crystals.
As a little bonus, we also have,
as a result, 17 of the
three dimensional
space groups.
Just imagine each of these
plane groups with a
translation perpendicular to the
plane of the plane group,
and that would leave all the
symmetry elements coincidence.
So you could pick a third
translation at right angles to
the blackboard of any arbitrary
length, and you
would have a three dimensional
lattice that contain the
symmetries of a plane group.
I think I mentioned earlier that
the way you distinguish a
plane group with a twofold axis
in it from a space group
with a twofold axis is that
a lowercase letter for the
lattice type implies plane
group, and an uppercase
symbol, capital P stands
for a primitive
lattice in a space group.
So something like lowercase p4mm
is a plane group, capital
P4mm is a space group with a
third translation of arbitrary
length at right angles
to the plane group.
We talked about plane groups and
space groups, let's take a
giant leap backwards.
How about the one dimensional
space groups?
Bet you were wondering about
them all along and
were afraid to ask.
So what would be the story
for one dimension?
It's nontrivial.
A one dimensional space group
would be a lattice row.
You have just one dimension to
play with, and you can make
that space periodic
by translation.
So there's one lattice type.
Just the lattice row.
And what sort of symmetries
could you
place in that lattice?
Now you have to define
your ground rules.
In our two dimensional
symmetries, we did not permit
any operation which would pick
the two dimensional space up
and rotate it and flip it over
and put it down again, because
that is a transformation that
takes you out of that space
and pops you back into it.
And we will not in our
discussion of three
dimensional crystallography
consider symmetries operations
that take something, suck it
up into a fourth dimension
that we can't comprehend, and
then all of a sudden pop it
down in again, and suddenly
it appears.
I mean, that sounds bizarre.
We wouldn't want to do that.
So for plane groups, we did not
allow for any operation,
say a twofold axis that would
flip the object over and turn
it upside down.
But why not?
I mean this, is mathematics.
If it's your ballgame, you
can make up the rules.
So why couldn't we have a
twofold axis in the plane or
the plane group?
It would have to leave
the net invariant.
Well actually such entities
do exist, and
they have been derived.
They're called the two
sided plane groups.
And if you want to allow that
when you make up the game, you
can actually do that if
you wish to allow it.
And also there could be a mirror
plane in the plane of
the space that would take the
top side and relate it to the
bottom side.
So you can do that, you
can permit that.
That's a different beast
entirely, but you can allow
that to be one of the
transformations.
So for our one dimensional
space, I would submit to be
consistent with what we've done
and just finished in two
dimensions.
And what we will do in three,
we will not allow for any
operation that will take the
space and transform it into a
second or third dimension, and
then put it down again.
So that being the case, the
only operation that is
possible is a mirror point
that would reflect
things left to right.
And let me illustrate now
with some patterns.
There's the lattice point.
So let me put in some motifs.
and I have to make a one
dimensional motif, but to
distinguish the ends I'll take
a little artistic license and
make one end of the motif a
little fatter than the other.
Or alternatively, I could put
a little one dimensional
headlight on this
thing that would
shine just in one direction.
So here's a motif hung on every
lattice point, and so
this is no symmetry at all.
So the symmetry part of the
symbol would be one, and the
lattice is primitive, and what
do you think people use?
We've used lowercase symbols,
we used uppercase symbols,
what's left?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Greek?
PROFESSOR: Good try.
Gothic.
Actually, what you do is you use
a Gothic symbol with all
these nice little shaded
angular shapes.
That's a Gothich P, isn't it?
Yeah, that's a Gothic
P. It is.
It actually has thick and
thin parts, curved parts
[INAUDIBLE].
So that's P1.
What about another symmetry?
Well if we have a mirror point
in there, another possibility
would be to have these
motifs point
alternately left and right.
So I'll take some non one
dimensional license and say
that there would be mirror
points at these locations.
Really nice symmetry, but
actually it would be totally
wasted on these poor denizens
in a one dimensional world.
Life would be dull and
uninteresting because they
couldn't see anything except
the motif on either side of
them, because everything is
constrained to one dimension.
There's an old saying about sled
dogs that says if you are
not the lead dog, the scenery
is not very interesting.
And the same is true for these
poor people in a one
dimensional world.
They could never see the
elegance and beauty of that.
But in any case, that would be
Gothic P, no snickers, please,
and that would be m.
And those are the only two
possibilities and a one
dimensional space.
We have a couple minutes to go,
but I think this is a good
place to pause.
And I'll give just a brief
indication of coming
attractions.
We're now going to look at
point groups in three
dimensions, and a good way of
entering this much more
complex situation is to go back
to something analogous to
what we did for two dimensional
symmetries.
And I'm going to first consider
the arrangement of
rotation axes in three
dimensions.
We do not have the constraint
that all the rotation axes be
perpendicular to the plane of a
two dimensional space, being
therefore more properly
rotation points.
We've got three dimensions we
have to view a rotation axis
as extending infinitely in a
direction, and there's no
reason why we can't have another
rotation axis at an
angle to it.
But you know that already.
Everybody's heard about
cubic crystals.
Even if you think all crystals
are either body centered
cubic, primitive cubic, face
centered cubic, or complex,
four kinds of lattices.
But you've heard of cubic
crystals, in the cubic
crystals clearly the rotation
axes are inclined to one
another and arranged
spacially.
So we're going to ask the
nontrivial question, how can
we combine more than one
rotation axis at a time about
a common point in space?
And the constraint is going to
be that a rotation about the
first axis followed by a
rotation about the second
axis, wherever it is, is going
to have to turn out to be
something that is
crystallographically
compatible with a lattice.
So that's the constraint.
It's not an easy question.
And just to make you feel proud
of yourself when we get
through this, this uses a
geometry that is due to one of
the great mathematicians of
all time, Leonhard Euler.
Probably the most remarkable
thing about Euler was that
he's Swiss.
How many world class scientists
have you heard of
that come from Switzerland?
Not very many, and the reason is
it's such a small country,
and if genius occurs as a
certain fraction of the
population, that's not going
to happen very often in a
country like Lichtenstein
or Switzerland.
Have you ever heard of anybody
prominent in science who came
from Lichtenstein?
No, probably not.
OK, this then is going to
be a nontrivial piece of
mathematics for us, largely
because it involves spherical
trigonometry.
Which I'm sure if you've ever
heard of, you've forgotten,
and probably don't see
any utility in it.
OK, with that exciting prospect
in hand, I look
forward to seeing
you on Thursday.